l'environnement ce serait encore un
effet de la canicule
on trouve désormais des insectes venus
d'afrique en france
parmi eux par exemple un grand papillon
de nuit le sphinx à tête de maure
impressionnant mais inoffensif nicolas
chateauneuf parce quelqu'un
depuis l'été dernier le professeur
jacques reçoit un nombre inhabituel
d'appel avec à chaque fois la même
histoire celle d'une personne qui vient
de découvrir un insecte jusque là
inconnu sous nos latitudes
le plus célèbre d'entre eux c'est lui
acquerront tia atropos ce ou 5 sa tête
de mort en raison du motif situé sur son
thorax un papillon de nuit majestueux
mais que les scientifiques avaient plus
l'habitude de voir en afrique qu'elle a
compté belge il ya ce réchauffement
visible du climat et donc les extensions
de beaucoup d'espèces au monde petit à
petit vers le nord et ça c'est un
phénomène très générale pour la faune et
la flore
est-ce qu'elle menace les espèces
locales n'est pas impossible que
certaines de ces espèces occupe la niche
d'une autre espèce locale et que la
phase soit remonté soit disparaître
habituellement signalées dans le sud de
la france le sphinx à tête de maure à
cette année poussé la balade un peu plus
loin il a été observée en bretagne dans
les vosges et même dans le nord de la
france
alors autant s'habituer aux dimensions
de nos nouveaux amis et ne pas paniqué à
la vue d'une chenille de 16 cm au fond
de son jardin
en attendant peut être l'arrivée
d'autres espèces qui seront elles -
pacifique qu'un simple papillon